foreign
promotion of smart agriculture the
intelligent agriculture production
platform based on iot cloud Ai and other
emerging Technologies is becoming
increasingly mature
based on AI plus iot technology our
solution can connect environmental
factors monitor crop status and generate
an intelligent irrigation schedule
supported by an expert decision system
this illusion helps achieve precise
volume control for agricultural
irrigation enabled the best growing
environment for crops reduce irrigation
costs integrate field monitoring
capabilities and improve field
management and services
the solution can collect environmental
and crop information through monitoring
devices and sensors on this basis the
decisioning module can generate an
intelligent irrigation program the
intelligent water saving irrigation
system is a typical use case of AI in
agriculture the deployment of AI
technology along the agricultural value
chain unlocks broader value in Precision
agriculture
thank you